[Music]
[Music]
alright here we go everyone welcome to
the game Awards pre-show I am Jeff Keely
the main show is on the way at the top
of the hour and I can't wait to share it
with you but right now we're gonna recap
some of this year's nominees highlight
what's on the way presents some Game
Awards and unveil some of our many
never-before-seen world premieres this
is the fifth year of the game wards I
simply can't believe it and each year we
tried to build on the moments you love
with what we hear loud and clear from
the community actually it's a little
intimidating because we got such a great
response to last year's show you know
this year we're bringing back the game
Ward's Orchestra we're making that
bigger and better part of the show I
think in many ways we're expanding the
reach of the show to many more platforms
so you'll be able to watch it around the
world in a different language is what I
think is really important that we can
have people around the world kind of
share our night we're allowing people to
vote in new ways
you know gamers get to choose the
winners alongside our judge board and
this year you can vote on this court
server or you can vote on Twitter
Facebook even with your voice on Amazon
Alexa and Google assistant we have I
think more new games being announced
this year at the show than ever before
which is really exciting that a lot of
studios around the world we're working
in secret to kind of prepare for the
Game Awards one of the things we found
last year that fans really liked were
giveaways and special incentives to kind
of watch the show and earn things and
games that they love steam we did
something called a game giveaway which
was amazing and people just got excited
because if you were watching the show
Steam Santa would just sort of drop
games into your account if you were
lucky enough so we're doing that again
and we're expanding that in a lot of
really interesting ways we also do the
game awards sale and this is a chance
for gamers around the world to get
special offers on nominated games on
their favorite gaming system and this
year we're working again with
PlayStation Store with Xbox with
Nintendo eShop with Steam to create
special offers on the nominees and every
platform will do this differently
there'll be some games that are across
all some only on certain ones I hope
that people will see a game in the show
and say oh that's amazing
this just one I want to go buy this game
but I get a special offer on it tonight
let me go grab it and look the stories
that matter the most to me coming out of
the show are some times when these game
developers will call me up on the Monday
after a small indie team and say you
know what Jeff like it was cool we were
in the show but we actually sold like a
lot of games this weekend that makes all
the hard work worthwhile for everyone on
the team I think to know that these
developers have a platform and we can
drive an audience to check out a game
that they're really going to love
now 2018 was an incredible year in
gaming and we say it every year but this
industry continues to get bigger and
better so been using this tagline worlds
will change in our promo campaign and I
think started with some people thinking
like this is the end o announcement of
this game but really the tagline to be
honest with you what it means is that a
lot of existing games have evolved this
year and unique in different ways I look
at some of the in-game storytelling the
fortnight's done with the rocket launch
and the cube and all these other moments
and how other games have evolved you
know no man's sky it's like nominated
this year and it's like it's a almost
completely you know new game then
they've been updating it so the worlds
will change really reflects the idea
that the games that we initially play
evolve over time used to be you would
you know get your cartridge get your CD
play the game move on now you keep those
games in your systems and what you're
going to see this year at the game
Awards is a lot of these sort of ongoing
game
are going to evolve at our show to an
interesting way so that's kind of a
tease of that theme that the world's you
know you may not know anymore after the
game wards we often get asked how we
pick the winners for the Game Awards the
nominees are selected by a jury of press
from around the world they're over 65
different publications or they often
have staffs that have played all these
games so we think that's the best way to
sort of survey everything out there in a
very neutral agnostic way and say hey
here are the the games that we think are
the best of the best those lead to the
nominees which have been announced and
then the winners are selected by a
blended vote between the jury and also
the public that gets to vote and help
influence it some people say like well
why don't you do a hundred percent fan
voting and a lot can be socially
engineered and I don't want awards to go
to games that just happen to you know be
able to have more twitter followers or
you know buy a bunch of ads to somehow
convince people to vote for them so I
really think it's important that the
right games win and we have an authentic
credible process and that's how we're
gonna continue with voting for the game
awards game of the year is such a
competitive category in 2018 it will be
Marvel's spider-man or Red Dead
Redemption this whole thing is very much
done good one or will it be God of War
close your heart to their desperation
so last
Assassin's Creed Odyssey to find who
will become
their monster hunter world you're on the
a-list right
we're about to find out at the end of
the night but right now here's a look at
our first world premiere
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Jeff Keely and welcome to the Microsoft
Theatre for the Game Awards 2018
everyone ready for a big shell this is
so exciting we have our biggest show
ever coming up at the top of the hour
there is so much news so many surprises
the game awards Orchestra we are
streaming live around the world in over
45 platforms I want to say to hide
everyone watching in China and India and
all across the world I know it's late in
Europe but stick around because we have
an amazing show ahead for you with
awards of course some new game
announcements I know everyone's
anticipating things stay tuned and a lot
of special guests we're gonna kick off
the show tonight or the pre-show before
we get to the main show at the top of
the hour with a guy who made some
headlines last year Joseph Farah is back
here at the game Awards
we thought we'd get to you early in the
night Joseph it's actually nice to be
the first guest to be honest with you
actually you should have the award look
what you put together man like thank you
this this guy said it's crazy it's five
years imagine in ten years what you will
do I hope I really I'm really proud to
be Ramudu happy to be back here and I'm
really excited to be here again
well you're a nominee tonight as well
congratulations for a game direction for
a way out I'm expecting to win so
hopefully I get up on stage say I could
only imagine your speech well Joseph
we're excited to have you here tonight
the internet wants to hear from you
right how do you think we're doing this
year compared to the other award shows
that just started but I feel like it's
becoming bigger and bigger and I'm
telling you in five years this is gonna
be the craziest thing ever in the whole
world can respect that's what this short
connection with autism no that's one
thing the last year when I was here
people thought it was crazy I mean I am
a bit crazy but it's the audience and
like the way they were like generation
around the world yeah we all love games
all right I can't see the people in the
world I love I love games of course
thank you very much it's great to be
here great girl right well Joseph you
are here for another purpose right now
we're gonna give away our first award of
the evening for best action game and
let's take a look right now at the
nominees for best action game this year
as voted on by the jury and fans the
action game nominees are call of duty
black ops 4 dead cells destiny 2
forsaken Far Cry 5
and Megaman 11 Joseph we'd love for you
to do the honors and let us know who
wins best action game this year the best
action games is dead cells dead cells
can graduation of guys promotions win
hello how are you guys nice to meet you
guys looking very dapper and this is for
you right here a game oh and it's heavy
thank you so much the stage is yours
it's ready hello my god congratulations
how's it feel this is so unexpected that
you around prepared a speech for this
actually just a special thought for the
whole team back in France hopefully
watching us at 3 a.m. in the morning I
hope you guys are awake because you just
made it so congratulations you should be
proud of yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for our incredible community of
fans
it may only be cliche but we couldn't
have done it without them so thank you
so much for your support
it's really amazing yeah
ready and expected and we're really
proud for our fans in all everyone who
loved the game it was incredible you
guys did a great job thanks for coming
all this way to the game on your first
of many game awarenss we hope thanks
very much guys thank you congratulations
Joseph thank you as well another trophy
maybe with your name on a ferris alright
we've got some more world premieres to
get to you here before we get to the
main show at the top of the hour right
now we're gonna take a look at the first
game from a new studio up in Montreal
Canada typhoon it's published by 505
games with support from Epic Games and
makers fund check out the announce for
this title
airlock reach
everyone
and increasing the system engaged once
again we would like to thank you for
joining the program
[Applause]
oxygen was critical
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that was the announcement of journey of
the savage planet I'm now here with Alex
Hutchinson one of the founders of the
new indie team at typhoon studios so
first of all Alex welcome to the show
why did you guys start this new studio
up in Montreal I think it's that moment
in life you know we've been doing this
about 15 years for myself making games
for other people so it's incredibly
amazing to see a game we built on our
own from nothing with friends of ours in
the business and to see it on you at
your show on the big screen is super
fulfilling so in a weird way that's the
that's the start of the reason why all
right well we love supporting new teams
tell us a bit about during the savage
planet kind of a teaser trailer so what
kind of game isn't yeah so everyone
what's the teaser and they always say is
it is it a you know a battle royale no
it's absolutely not a battle royale is
it a survival game no it is not it's an
adventure game you get dropped on a
strange alien world by a company called
kindred aerospace who are very proud to
be the fourth best interstellar space
exploration company so they drop you
there with absolutely no gear high hopes
and no ability and they hope that you
can solve the the mystery of what's on
the savage planet okay and how can we
find out more about this game we don't
get updates so we're not gonna show much
gameplay until next year but we're very
excited to do it so we'll show you
gameplay and all kinds of new bits and
pieces as soon as we start next year
all right so get ready for 2019 Alex
thank you so much for coming down and
showing your game for the first time
here at the game Awards I really
appreciate it all right now we're gonna
move on to present another award now for
the best role-playing game and the
nominees in this genre category are
Dragon Quest 11
monster hunter world ninokuni - octo
path traveller and pillars of eternity -
and this is an award I get to give out
for best role-playing game let me open
this one up and the winner for best
role-playing game goes to monster hunter
world congratulations
[Applause]
congratulations congratulations it's for
you guys how does it feel
photo op how's it feel yeah yeah
yo Gotti's very great that we actually
were able to come to come from Japan
welcome mr. ghajini game are they show
to lydiana tight on his tiny dick I have
another talent creating the game this
game we were talking with amongst the
team members that it is kind of our goal
to actually be able to hear be here and
receive the old somebody nope you can
abandon all the new diseases so we made
the we made it full circle that means a
lot to all of us thank you so much you
know condemn our area now say we will
have great news for our hands soon I'll
soon like tonight soon Suzie to look
like a few days later okay all right
scratch that off your bingo card all
right well congratulations guys I'm
winning the best RPG four months are and
congratulations on being nominated for
Game of the Year as well so maybe we'll
see you guys again on stage
guys congratulations awesome alright
thank you very much well you know
there's been a lot of gaming
conversation happening on Twitter this
year using the hashtag the game Awards
and to celebrate Twitter decide to
create their first Twitter gaming award
you the fans voted for the best
conversation and the winner out of all
the big things that happened this year
was spider-man's ps4 photo mode so you
can go to Twitter gaming now to see the
announcement video of that winner and of
course tweet up a storm all night about
the game awards there's some big news
breaking that you definitely will want
to be talking about now we're also back
on twitch this year we've got an
interactive extension that lets you
predict the winners throughout the show
their coach streaming but there's also
this interactive extension so you can go
online to the Game Awards channel pick
your winners throughout the night and at
the end of the show we'll share the
final leaderboard and see who predicted
the most Awards correctly alright well
we've got some other awards to get to
now it's been an absolutely huge year
for eSports and coming up at the top of
the hour in the main show the best
eSports player award will be presented
by omen by HP but right now it's my
honor to announce some of the other
winners in many of these sports
categories that we added this year to
the show so for the best eSports team
here are the nominees cloud nine has won
this I think the past two or three years
so we've got Australis cloud 9 fnatic
London Spitfire and og and the winner
this year again is cloud 9 so
congratulations to Jack and the entire
organization of cloud 9 now for the best
eSports game the nominees this year were
csgo
dota 2 fortnight League of Legends
overwatch
all right it's a crowd favorite I guess
and the game award goes to overwatch for
the best eSports game make that one last
year as well all right next up the best
eSports event the nominees is a new
category this year the e League major
Boston 2018 back in January evo 2018
this summer in Vegas the League of
Legends World Championship the overwatch
League grand finals and the
International 2018 up in Vancouver and
the League of Legends World Championship
wins congratulations - lol alright best
eSports host those nominees were Alex
golden boy Mendes Alex Machine
Richardson Anders Blum I apologize fj
Shox depo Terry I know she's in Las
Vegas tonight and Paul Ridd I shall
endure and the game award goes to Shox
congratulations
next up the best eSports coach those
nominees are reapered parasail zonic
dylan Falco and Yamato cannon and ynk
and the best eSports coach as voted by
the fans Reaper congratulations to him
now best eSports moment this is the top
moment as voted on by the jury and fans
first up with C nines comeback win in
triple overtime vs. phase
g2 beating RNG kt vs. IG base race and
oh jeez massive upset of LGD and Sonic
Fox who's a nominee for Best eSports
player side switch against go on in DBZ
and the winner is C nines comeback win
in triple OT versus phase
congratulations again to c9
all right but we've got more eSports
coming up in the main show but right now
we've got another world premiere this is
a favorite game of mine from a couple of
years ago and they reached out to me a
couple weeks ago and say hey we've got
something more we're doing we want to
share with you at the game Awards so
check that check this out I think you'll
like it this is a story of a video game
called the Stanley parable you know the
Stanley parable of course after all it
was the video game sensation of 2013
don't you remember all those awards we
were nominated for and this year's
winner for Best narrative is the Last of
Us The Last of Us last five papers
please The Last of Us papers please the
Last of Us yes it was thrilling to be so
unanimously recognized by our peers
which is why we've lost the games source
code away where it can never be touched
by the greedy hand of capitalism a
pristine time capsule of perfect
artistic integrity to be preserved for
wait what do you mean we never put the
game on consoles of course we put it on
consoles
we didn't excuse me a moment
day
gotcha
Stanley I've had a great idea I want to
add new endings and new content new
adventures for you won't it be fun
Oh shush of course it will we'll package
it up with the original game and we'll
put it on consoles and everyone will buy
it again because they're suckers come
come daddy needs a third swimming
[Applause]
what do you mean the last of us to is
also coming up next year all right it's
definitely parable back again now is my
honor to present the award for the best
student game judged by an incredible
panel including Megan Ellison from
Annapurna Todd Howard
Jenova Chen and my good friend had a
Okajima the nominees are combat 2018
from Norway - quasar from UC Santa Cruz
Jarrah from DigiPen in Spain life from
ice art digital in France and recharge
from MIT and I'm happy to announce the
best student game and congratulations
all the students who are here with us in
the audience the best student game goes
to combat 2018 from Norway this is yours
the first of many game awards I hope how
does it feel congratulations it's
amazing to be on the list for the
student game thank you so much for
having this award that's really great
congratulations to you guys and
hopefully your game will come out soon
we'll get to play it yeah and August
hopefully we're actually working on the
game and the new name okay thank the
jury and all the people who voted for us
and of course our team Maki Nero stage
with me and Aurora and Thomas them back
in Norway and of course our school in
Norway University of Applied Sciences
and of course our mentor who are we
about to a special thank to you awesome
well congratulations guys we hope to see
more of your game that student game
Award winner we love doing that award
all right we another world premiere for
you this is from a small indie team of
three guys who have been working on this
game for the past five years it's called
among trees and when I saw some footage
of this I said we've got to share it
with you so check this out
[Music]
all right well now it's the top of the
hour that means I think it's time for
the game Awards are you guys ready you
know this show is all about bringing
everyone together to celebrate video
games when I started this show five
years ago my dream was to put
competition aside and just come together
to celebrate what we love which is
playing games making games and this is a
moment it's been five years in the
making for me I can't believe it's about
to happen but to kick off the show I
couldn't think of anything better than
this please join me in welcoming from
Nintendo Reggie fils-aime a from
PlayStation Shawn Layden
and from Xbox phil spencer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight at the game Awards we come
together as a community to celebrate
videogames the most compelling and
immersive form of entertainment in the
world as an industry we are most
powerful when we come together united by
our common love for the art form of
games we join with the viewers and
gamers around the globe to celebrate
creativity innovation and the role that
video games play in popular culture
together we will continue to invite new
voices creators and players into our
worlds because when everybody plays we
all win because when we see the strength
of a united gaming community we remember
that we've never seen the challenge that
you can't defeat
were united in our commitment to leading
and pushing this industry Ford with new
games new experiences and new ways for
everyone to play good luck to all the
nominees and congratulations to all the
winners and enjoy the game Awards Jeff
take it away thank you so much guys
Reggie Sean and Phil together on stage
it's what this show is all about we have
an amazing show ahead for you guys and
we are gonna kick things off with an
incredible performance by the game
awards orchestra conducted by our
amazing musical directors Lauren valve
featuring the legendary Hans Zimmer and
Harry gregson-williams
and they will be joined by a nominee
tonight Lena rain and Sarah Shatner they
are premiering our brand new theme for
the game awards I can't believe it enjoy
the show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here's the creator of the game Awards
Jeff Keely
[Applause]
how about that the Game Awards Orchestra
Hans Zimmer Harry gregson-williams lorne
balfe with Sarah and Lena what an
amazing start to the show welcome to the
Gabel arts everybody wow this is so cool
and we are live around the world on over
45 platforms and tonight millions of
people around the world are coming
together to do one thing which is
celebrate the video games that we love
so thank you all for joining me and
thank you we've got an amazing show for
you we've got a show filled with of
course awards some new game
announcements many things that you've
been rumored online may happen tonight
and we've had an amazing year for games
so let's get right to the show with our
first big award of the night to present
our first award he's a mega popular
youtuber and she's a twitch streamer
nominated tonight for content creator of
the year
please welcome jacksepticeye and pokey
merry
[Applause]
[Applause]
we're pretty lucky and that we're able
to play games for a living and so to all
the developers here and watching around
the world thank you for doing what you
do and making the games that we love yes
thank you
we're here to present the award for best
narrative these are the games whose
stories captivated us with complex
characters surprising twists and
profound philosophical ideas here are
the nominees best narrative I didn't
choose to be different
to start the war
you did the head is more
[Applause]
this is a nightmare I know who you are
and what you did
what you and your brother have is the
most important thing
[Applause]
it needs our help
anyone left in New York who doesn't want
me dead
be careful out there
this is pasty country
and the game award goes to Red Dead
Redemption too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's amazing thank you from the entire
team at Rockstar to all our fans
everyone who voted for us we love
telling stories just as much as we love
creating worlds and it's been incredible
seeing people connect to the game and go
on Arthur's journey for themselves I'd
like to thank our amazing cast they
brought this to life in ways we didn't
even imagine and you can see tonight and
across this category it's been an
outstanding year for games and
storytelling and there's still so far we
can take it so on to the next one thank
you very much
[Applause]
throughout the night we're gonna take a
look at the future of games with world
premieres now some of them you've
probably heard of and some of them you
definitely haven't we've got some good
surprises tonight and this is one of
those that no one is gonna see coming
enjoy
idiots
your stupidity may have doomed the
universe wouldn't be the first time
sweetheart
Oh for pose our master shelf
[Music]
man
had its chance to move
Cheers
[Music]
Spyder
[Music]
turning like to see a chai scrappy
[Music]
[Music]
when the black order
[Music]
prevalence
[Music]
we do it as a team
[Music]
I shall be waiting here for you please
welcome and after and the writers
director of the film mid-90s
here's Jonah Hill
[Music]
[Applause]
shoutout to woody Jackson the best
composer in the world
I am honored to be here tonight to
introduce someone who has truly changed
gaming forever someone who in his own
words just wanted to make killer games
with his friends and ended up making
some of the world's most memorable
titles thirty years ago he and his
friends started with nothing they worked
in a small basement under a nurses call
center over the years Greg Thomas and
his team at visual concepts created
iconic games by following a simple
recipe hard work strong ideas in a
passionate team and that rep is recipe
gave us NBA 2k Greg yeah give it up
Gregg is a humble giant but his
forward-thinking passion and dedication
excellence has made his name known
throughout the industry let's take a
look back at his highlight reel industry
icon
[Music]
this is the NFL on the Sega Sports
Network let's see if they can hit
charities and welcome everybody to the
ESPN halftime show
[Applause]
the speaker's baby
2k sports venture League baseball action
backs wall struck in Iowa
[Applause]
da right here on 2k sports greatest
basketball game before this game bigger
than the court
[Applause]
King thus far from finished
very cool I am honored to introduce the
2018 industry icon the legend the myth
the goat mr. Greg Thomas
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Joanna it's such an honor to
be introduced by you see a compilation
of the games that we've created over the
last 30 years is also very humbling for
anyone who knows me
you know I've shied away from the
spotlight I'm not very comfortable being
in the center of attention
this has never been about making a name
for myself it's always been about making
great games but this is an incredible
honor first I need to thank my beautiful
wife and family for allowing me to do
everything I've always loved to do there
have been many sacrifices and they have
been patient loyal and understanding
through it all I love you all very much
thank you
and none of this would be possible
without my business partner and
co-founder Scott Patterson and my
brother and the leader of the NBA 2k
team Jeff Thomas I'd love to you guys
who join me on stage
we've been together since the very
beginning and we've always shared the
same values and passions when it comes
to making games we never imagined that
over the years visual concepts would
grow to where we are today with six
worldwide studios in more than 350
employees the philosophy has never
changed it's all family to me I also
want to thank David hiss Mahler Carlos
laid-off and Strauss element from 2k and
tattoo for believing in me and giving us
the freedom to make games our way and I
and I owe everything to my management
team this team has been together for a
long time the culture of the company has
always been about believing in our
people it's because we love working
together and we all believe in the same
things and I need to thank all of their
families as well for supporting us and
putting up with us that can't be easy
thank you so much
without these people there is no Greg
Thomas receiving an award there is no
visual concepts they are the real icons
and I share this award with them thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations Greg now tonight the
game Awards on Facebook gaming are
recognizing global gaming citizens
people who are enriching the lives of
others around the world through video
games we're gonna tell some stories
tonight of three people that I think you
should meet and hear their stories and
I'm so proud to have these in the game
Awards first up Steven spawn from
AbleGamers please take a look at his
story I don't know how I got where I am
or what I'm doing all I wanted to do was
figure out how to play video games and
along the way I figured out that I can
help other people play video games when
I was coming out of high school I went
to my guidance counselor to figure out
what's next in life for me
they'd sat across the table for me and
they told me that I should go home and
have fun with my remaining years because
I'm going to die soon anyway they told
me to just go home and die that's the
time it kicked me down but now it's a
memory that I look back on and I
realized that you can be disabled you
can be productive you can be a valuable
contributing member of society and you
can change the world by doing a few
things along the way that no one else is
willing to do
I'm proud to be one of the leaders
available gamers and helping people with
disabilities be able to conquer the
challenges of getting back into playing
video games my mission is to enable
people to use technology to reach out to
connect with the world that was
otherwise inaccessible they're able to
the greater quality of life by having
people in little eyes
[Music]
amazing Steve in Iraq three years ago
psionics burst onto the scene and
rocket-powered soccer has never been the
same with more than 52 million players
worldwide
it's a two-time winner at the game
awards and now rocket league is
revealing their latest DLC right here
check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
coming up Christoph Waltz and Rosa
Salazar hand out the award for best
performance and later more surprise game
announcements and musical performances
this is the Game Awards 2018 wake up
wake up the time has come for paths to
defeat and treasures want and impossible
tales to be sung
as we take on our foes together as one
[Music]
till we send our ears back to where they
came from wake up wake up the time has
come
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
from our smash brothers ultimate coming
soon
in fact we're hours away maybe
[Applause]
right now we've got an exclusive
action-packed clip from the new film
Elita battle angel directed by Robert
Rodriguez and produced by James Cameron
and come to theaters February 14th check
this out run
my god rip that plea
[Music]
watch your time
[Music]
[Applause]
from the upcoming film alina battle
angel please welcome
Rosa Salazar and a two-time Academy
Award winner
Kristof walls
[Applause]
to deliver a powerful game performance
you must humanize a digital puppet made
of polygons and textures in a sense the
actor plays the surrogate for their
audience they're an entry point into the
games world and personalities then
unlike any medium the connection
continues and strengthens when the
player controls that very character with
an analog stick
I prefer mouse and keyboard I'm not
gonna do this with you look I mean
aim-assist is just dumb okay
these are the nominees for Best
Performance Best Performance for me it
was strong female characters that I
happen to know join us in battle
alright Spartan I'll fight with you
I didn't choose to be different to
betray my own kind follow orders you
have anything to say in your defense to
be effective in combat award
his enemy from Amana thank you you're
not
we have more than that spider-man look
next time leave the fighting to the pros
okay but if there are any around
this whole thing is pretty much done
ghosts people we get paid or you get
shot I'm happy
and the game award goes to Roger Clark
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I guess this is the part where words
that make sense they're supposed to come
out of my mouth
thank you I humbly accept this honor
especially in light of the amazing
performances of my fellow nominees to
share this moment in time with all of
you a moment in time which is clearly
becoming the advent of a golden age of
this medium I gotta thank my wife Molly
I love you Molly for five years she
watched me come home from long days of
performance capture and kindly reminded
me to check Arthur at the door put the
kids to bed
that reminds me Colin already go to bed
I would also like to thank Rockstar
Games for the amazing opportunity the
faith that they put in me thank you
thank you all this is amazing moment
[Applause]
he was the narrative director for one of
the biggest games in Ubisoft history far
cry 5 and he's here right now to unveil
the next chapter please welcome John
Sebastian decocked
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone as you may remember [ __ ]
high five indeed with nukes dropping on
Montana and this marked the very
beginning of a brand new world because
yes we're finally bringing the post
apocalypse to Fekkai and as the creative
director of this new project
it is my absolute pleasure to reveal to
you [ __ ] hi new dawn
[Applause]
we were just kids when the bombs dropped
and the world went to [ __ ] they said it
was supposed to be the end of everything
but for us it was just the beginning
[Applause]
surviving nah we were better than that
this new world had a lot to give and we
took it all that's how we came out on
top that's how we got here
that's how we found you
[Music]
you need to understand something the
only currency left in this world is
power we're gonna take everything from
you
starting with your home and if we can't
take you
we'll break
[Music]
[Music]
I led us into the new world I thought
that it would be glorious I was wrong
far cry new dawn now tonight you can
also find special offers on all our
nominated games across Xbox Live
Nintendo eShop steam and the PlayStation
Store so make sure to check your
favorite place to get games for some
special offers on nominees and more
right now we've got another world
premiere check this out
[Music]
where do you think you are who do you
think you're talking to nobody gets out
of my domain whether alive or dead you
wish to learn the hard way
fine then girl get out don't let me stop
you wasn't planning on it father
[Music]
well I'm home
well time to go get killed again
[Music]
death is your only family den and I
[Music]
congratulations the guys from supergiant
that is an early access title they're
gonna be updating overtime and it's
available tonight right now on the epic
games store so congratulations Greg Amir
and the entire team there at supergiant
I am here now with my friend Patrice
Desilets the designer behind Assassin's
Creed famously and you're working on a
new project called ancestors a humankind
Odyssey Patrice tell us about this game
you're right Jeff first thank you for
having me quite an honor for me to be
here thank you
so yes I'm working on ancestors the
humankind Odyssey it is a single-player
open-world exploration survival game it
is set in Africa starting ten million
years ago
we're basically players will play from
the last common and ancestors of all the
big apes up to Lucy the famous
Australopithecus okay that's a lot of
game there tell us a bit about where
you're at in this game and what we're
gonna see tonight is you're gonna show
us some gameplay right Oh totally
totally so this game is then it's done
by panache digital games my new studio
back in Montreal 30 people hi everyone
and tonight I'm gonna show four clips of
actual game play me playing last week
okay
this is real mistakes exactly and yes
people like what they see they can go on
GameSpot and see another 20 minutes of
me playing the very beginning of the
game after the show all right you're
showing it all here it is ancestors of
humankind Odyssey Thank You Patrice
pleasure
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
games play best on Xbox one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
girl's main games is the program that
inspires girls to make games it teaches
them the tools that they need to get
from start where they know nothing to
get to a full develop prototype and
dreams my favorite part about camp doing
the designing for the how the platform
is my experience with Genji has given me
the confidence to pursue author writing
and video game project the whole mission
is just amazing to really inspire young
girls to learn to make games and really
get the female perspective and voice in
games
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have so much more game Awards to come
right now here's another world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's your first look at scavengers and
I'm now here with Josh homes from
midwinter Josh tell us a bit about your
studio
yeah well so midwinter's a new studio up
in Seattle Washington we're a relatively
small team we're just over 20 people
many of us come from triple-a background
working on titles like Halo and
battlefield and this is our first game
as a new studio
all right so scavengers we got a tease
of sort of the world they're some of the
characters what kind of game is it
so scavengers is a survival shooter
coopertition it's it's a game where
teams need to cooperate to survive but
compete to win so what we're doing is
we're taking all of the aspects of a
survival game is sort of condensing that
into a replayable session-based
multiplayer experience awesome all right
and if people want to learn more saw a
little tag there to sign up right yeah
yeah for us it's it's so important to
have players have a voice in shaping the
game and and so starting in 2019 we're
gonna be having play tests and people
can go right now go to scavengers game
comm sign up and you'll be among the
first to play scavengers in 2019
awesome all right well thank you so much
for putting that together it's an
amazing world premiere first look at
scavengers Josh sign up for that now all
right it's now time to present our next
award and please welcome the frontman
from panic at the disco to do it Brendon
Urie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I just want to say what an honor it is
to be here first off and secondly I have
to apologize because I was supposed to
write something last night but I stayed
up til 5:00 a.m. playing season seven a
fortnight so I apologize oh wait never
mind they wrote it for me okay
personally as a musician I'm constantly
amazed by the skills of the composers in
this industry that make tracks that
elevate all the action and tension and
set the perfect mood here are the
nominees best score music presented by
Spotify
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay the award goes to Red Dead
Redemption too
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thanks
I wasn't expecting it but thanks a lot
thanks to my wife Sharon Jackson my two
daughters George Washington Jackson and
Theodore Roosevelt Jackson to make sure
I get that out
i they've been all the games their heart
beats since the past ten years so I
really appreciate my family and use them
appropriately not a comedian but I try
to play one sometimes rock star my
surrogate family thank you so much and
this guy came in and did the most
beautiful sad music thank you yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
to Daniel and woody and speaking of
score and soundtrack I want to let you
know I've got a new podcast series with
Spotify six episodes called score points
we're actually went behind the scenes
and interviewed a lot of the composer's
nominated there including woody about
Red Dead Redemption to bear about God
award John about spider-man Lena about
Celeste so Lauren about FIFA so lots of
great stuff make sure to check that out
tonight on Spotify it's called score
points right now I'd like to recognize
some other winners tonight in other
major categories the best audio design
presented by Dolby and these are the
nominees in that category call of duty
black ops for forts our horizon for god
of war Marvel's spider-man and Red Dead
Redemption - and the game award for best
audio design goes to Red Dead Redemption
- it's having a pretty good night
alright for best art direction the
nominees in this craft category are
Assassin's Creed Odyssey God of War octo
path traveler Red Dead Redemption - and
return of the Oh burden and the winner
is return of the over dead
congratulations to Lucas Pope who I know
is here tonight
next up the category of best mobile game
and those nominees are donut county
Florence
fortnight Pub G mobile and Raines Game
of Thrones and the game award for best
mobile game goes to Florence
congratulations the mountains nana
Poorna all right best VRA our game those
nominees are Astro bot rescue mission
beat Sabre firewall zero our boss and
Tetris effect an astro bot rescue
mission is the winner for best VRA our
game congratulations now on twitch
everyone is voting right now to select
who they think it's gonna win in major
categories content creator of the Year
is coming up and let's see what the
twitch poll is predicting it looks like
people are predicting that Ninja is
going to win that one with 49 percent of
the votes
we'll find out ninjas in the house along
with many other content creators all
right well next up warframe it's at its
biggest year yet it just launched for
tuna the newest open-world expansion on
PC
and it's coming to Xbox and ps4 on
December 10th that's some breaking news
and for the first time ever you can play
warframe anywhere on the switch here's a
look at warframe for Nintendo switch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I thought I knew why I came here I saw
it
you set the apocalypse in motion I won't
let that happen
if you had the power to alter the course
of humanity what would you do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm here with Matt Cote who is the game
director for dead by daylight we just
saw that Matt welcome to the game Awards
thank you very much it's such an honor
to be here it's great to have lots of
Canadian Montreal teams up here which
I'd love to see my home country Canada
I hear you've got some big plans for the
game right it's true I mean we we plan
to keep this game alive for at least the
next five years and to show our
dedication essentially tonight we're
announcing the dedicated servers are
coming to dead by daylight this summer
okay summer 2019 yep and I also want to
show the trailer for the very first time
for a new chapter coming two dead by
daylight darkness among us okay let's
take a look at that another world
premiere thanks so much appreciate it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm back here now with Casey Hudson the
general manager at Bioware another
Canadian companies the Canada section
right all right well you're almost done
with anthem Casey tell us where are you
ads coming early next year right yeah
it's coming out in February and so we've
got you know Marc Terra and the team are
doing an incredible job finishing it up
it's almost done and yeah we're super
happy to be here and be able to show a
little bit more of the game tonight so
what are we gonna see tonight from the
game well so a lot of what we've shown
so far is the gameplay it's super fun
you're basically you know an armored
superhero in a fantasy setting and we've
shown a lot of that we haven't really
let people in on what the story is and
the characters and things like that but
you know like a great Bioware game we're
building out a whole world of story and
things for you to discover and
characters to me so we're gonna start
letting you in on a little bit more of
that I know the entire team is working
very hard on this right yeah I mean
we've got a big team working on it but
we've got a few projects at Bioware so
it's not the only thing that we're
working on and so we do have a few
surprises left okay but anthem right now
at them right now and uh always thinking
about our next thing all right
I tried all right here's a look at
anthem check it out
I have seen the power of the anthem
destroy entire civilizations you have no
idea what the heart of race could do
that person I feel a new power it's
calling me generations our people
struggle just to survive ready go the
javelins allowed us to fight back the
chaos
[Music]
and the walls protected our families
loved ones remember we're a team I'm
right there with you as a freelancer job
always has been
but the anthem still rages
and walls can only do so much
but with the power of the anthem at my
tips
[Applause]
I will Bend
this needless suffering
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the game awards continues everybody is
here tonight including crash bandicoot
you deserved a trophy of your own thank
you very much crash this is the
standard-issue crash crate should I show
how do I open this thing
I think maybe give it a good spin that
should do it yeah just run I got a log
show the hosts I'm just gonna open it
very professionally here and that's good
oh wow what's what's this this kind of
looks familiar doesn't know
booyah grandma booyah let's check out
the world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they're two of the voices from God of
War
please welcome sunny Soulja and
Christopher judge
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dames have always had a strong sense of
community I remember when I was a kid
younger gathering around someone at the
arcade who was close to breaking high
score but I'm blown away by how much
bigger that community is in today's
connected age millions of people around
the world aren't just playing games they
love their watching their favorite
online personality stream for hours at a
time these are the nominees for the
content creator of the Year content
creator of the year
oh my god there we go
Oh touch myself it's something that I
enjoy being able to bring joy to others
doing something that you enjoy is here
[Music]
and the game award goes to rien boy
the award goes to ninja
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie this is an incredible
honor first off just like to thank my
lovely wife Jessica who's joining me
today and my family who supported me my
entire life they've always let me play
video games as long as I was just a
little bit more active outside so but
you know this has just been an
incredible year for gaming and video
games and I'm just honestly blessed to
be in the position that I'm in to have
won this award and to bring joy to all
the people who who loved watching video
games so I mean I think it's crazy that
every single person in this room and
every single person watching it's all
because of video games so I mean here's
to another incredible year 2019 thank
you guys so much I appreciate it
[Applause]
from obsidian please welcome the creator
and game designer of fallout here are
Tim Payne
and Leonard Boyarsky
[Applause]
it's hard to believe it's been 20 years
since we made fallout and 13 years since
we last work together at troika yeah and
it's great to be reunited on a new
single-player RPG we're very excited to
review our brand new game and our brand
new universe the outer worlds we hope
you enjoy it oh wait hold on a second
you weren't supposed to say that
remember yeah what we're supposed to say
is by watching this trailer you are
legally obligated to enjoy it thank you
thank you
[Applause]
there you are wondering what's going on
eh
one question first are you feeling
anything that can be construed as
explosive cell death no wonderful let's
get started
[Music]
welcome to the edge of the galaxy the
frontier of space well at least it was
until the corporation's bought it
branded it and started selling it at
ludicrously inflated prices and the rest
of your fellow settlers abandoned on the
edge of the colony I'd save them myself
but the Boers got a bounty on my head so
that's why I thought you out you appear
capable
look I get it taking on the corporation
is left us the two choices bad and worse
but you have to choose and you have to
choose now you know you didn't have to
shoot either one right but it's fine I
guess you just keep being you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Spicer's choices not responsible for any
feeling of vertigo under or hundred you
may've experienced while watching this
advertisement all right that's the
brand-new title from obsidian thanks for
that and check out this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now Jesse Houston the CEO of Phoenix
labs a couple years ago you were with us
announcing this game Jesse and now
you're back
we sure are and it's been quite a couple
of years and you know we're super
excited to not only talk about the last
couple years but also the future and you
know it's really awesome
coming into the future and being able to
see an April rather and launch the game
on xbox and ps4 and the epic platform
you know from the get-go Dauntless has
always been about bringing players
together with your friends and kill them
big behemoths and you know those firms
are gonna be kind of the next big
journey for us and tonight you got
something launch into right you sure do
so it's our biggest content expansion
pack frostfall drops today on PC at
Plato's calm all right we'll check it
out play dauntless thank you very much
Jesse Canadian company all right we'll
be right back after this when I was
growing up I didn't see any women doing
a lot of bigger things in my life there
not much expectation from girls for even
the girls education is not like they
take a top priority I'm from a very
humble background it was difficult for
me to pursue this to make money to be
able to afford the private school so
that I can go and study computer science
getting education it's not about just
getting degree it's actually getting
exposure to the world you can't be if
you can't see
that's what we are trying to do is give
them an inspiration Vexilar James
Academy is a training academy for
videogame development
our main focus is actually improving
game developers and creative artists to
be able to make their own game idea this
is my Vegas train I want people to see
what kind of ideas what kind of a
creative people we have in Pakistan
coming up Joel McHale recognizes best
eSports player and a musical performance
of Devil Trigger and later an exciting
announcement from fortnight this is the
game Awards
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Super Smash Brothers ultimate I hope you
have the stamina because the games about
to be in stock and it's almost hi
[Music]
welcome to my store it's one not bound
by walls or limited by inventory
or restricted by time
the rule here is to untether your
imagination
[Applause]
[Music]
watch it stop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight we've got some of the biggest
franchises in the world unveiling their
new games we've also got some smaller
studios sharing their projects this is
another one of those surprises enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
and you don't know oh it's worth
[Music]
through the Shadowlands 10 forgotten and
as you will find
[Music]
like a novel you must fight
interesting as well do not forget
before
you were born to take the greatest
[Music]
the second
[Music]
until the place is no man tends to
follow
[Music]
and now here's actor and comedian Joel
McHale
[Applause]
yeah hi Jeff
Wow I can't believe you had me back when
I was asked to present the award for
best eSports player I did not hesitate
video games have brought me and my son's
closer together every morning they fire
up shocker fortnight and their eyes
light up with a promise of a new day and
they demand my credit-card information
to purchase a moist Emer man skin and a
guiding glow axe Wow
it seems like only yesterday they were
forcing me to buy a rainbow rider an
Astro back playing huh they grow up so
fast anyway
I'm okay eSports continued to grow
exponentially every year with sold-out
arena tournaments all over the world and
millions of dollars on the line this
award recognizes the most dominant
athlete in eSports whomever wins this is
basically the LeBron James of sitting
it's amazing here are the nominees best
eSports player presented by omen by HP
this kid could do it - take it off sonic
bought the tip
here's your champion
[Applause]
I was too far back
that is stunning from simple
he's looking dangerous
Oh
[Music]
okay and the game award goes to sonic
Fox everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh wow I really wonder skin oh my god
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yes I wanna say this is big honor uh I
kind of just really really enjoy playing
video games competitively I've never
really really done it for the fame I
kind of just enjoy the rush stuff like
beating people up you know like even one
like I'm sure you guys heard the story
of when I won the IPS finale the other
thing I don't do this for the money
it's cuz when my best friend my best
friend one of my closest friends over
gotta marry his that had cancer and
after I won before I even like did the
match I told him whether I win or lose
I'm gonna be donating at least like 10k
of the prize winning to his father for
his stage three cancer they hope it
works out for him and he really I mean I
guess I never really just gonna just
make new friends and bonds in the
communities so I guess for now I can
want to give a shout outs so obviously
the teammates helped me do that all the
way I go Fox I want to give a shout-out
to all my friends back out at home my
best friend to kill sage he's helping me
out so much through life we can in black
the gate the goons back at home game
guys also may know or may not know I'm
also super gay so I mean
so I went to get a super set up to all
my lgbtq+ friends that I've always
called me to life
obviously I'm a fairy so shout to the
fairies a very personal mayor guess all
I gotta say is that I'm gay black a
fairy pretty much everything about
publican hates and the best
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right I am here with Dave Kurt the
world art director at pub G corporation
Dave when he tell us about the the new
map besides the new train people can get
played tonight what else all right so
it's called vaq ND it's our first 6x6
map which is the sweet spot between the
chaos of sanic and the tactics of
arendelle it's also a snow map which
means you leave footprints
players can track you you can track them
hunter becomes the hunted what about new
gear this time around absolutely we're
gonna have the g36c assault rifle and a
very fast very new badass snowmobile to
explore the map in ok snowmobile and
we're gonna get to like jump that
snowmobile tonight cuz you're putting on
the test servers after the show yeah
it's the best news it's ready tonight PC
test servers and it's gonna be on Xbox
one and PlayStation 4 in January alright
so jump on Steam tonight for that and
also the ps4 version hits tomorrow right
yeah tomorrow December 7th PlayStation
we're super excited to join the
PlayStation community all of our new ps4
players are gonna receive an exclusive
parachute and finally it's your last
chance to pre-order which will grant the
nathan drake desert outfit from the
Uncharted series and Ellie's backpack
from The Last of Us get it all right
fantastic Dave really appreciate it Pub
G great to have you back with us again
alright now I'd like to introduce our
next presenters they're members of a
Grammy award-winning band that I love
personally from Weezer please welcome
Brian bow and Rivers Cuomo
[Applause]
what's up just a warning things are
about to get heavy if you got any
earplugs right now I'd like you to throw
them away just toss them anywhere also
if you have any religious artifacts put
those away just tuck them under your
seats because we're about to summon some
dark spirits here's the composer of
Devil May Cry 5 Casey Edwards with
vocals by Allie Edwards performing
Chapel true
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the darkest of night
the heart you with it
let it out
Stephens
worth a try
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right there was Devil Trigger
internets he wanted it over the last
three years nearly 20 million players of
tame train and ridden dinosaurs in the
epic Ark survival evolved tonight the
creators are unveiling their new
adventure a gigantic world of
exploration and conquest take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right I'm here with Jeremy and Jesse
from wild card studios guys
congratulations on the announcement
tonight coming next week what exactly is
Atlas
well Atlas is a massive open world
survival MMO for forty thousand
concurrent players in the same
environment it's a game about building
an armada claiming territory forming an
empire and ultimately dominating the
entire globe it's a huge scale how big
is the map it's really big
the Atlas world is 1,200 times the size
of a single arc server and our team has
spent countless hours hand crafting a
beautiful place to play in with biomes
from tropics to tundra desert polar
regions and we filled it with amazing
creatures everything from things you
would expect like livestock
- crazy mythological creatures that are
guarding the secrets of an ancient
civilization there's so much fun stuff
to see and do an atlas and it's just
gonna be awesome to engage in amazing
well coming to PC any word coming to
console yet Alice will be coming to
console next year - Xbox with the Xbox
game preview program we got great
feedback from the fans on arc for a game
preview and we're excited to bring it
first to Xbox next year awesome alright
well thanks guys I know lots of work
ahead in the week week ahead to launch
it we really appreciate it
we've also got our twitch poll
continuing so the Award for Best
independent game people have been voting
on that that's coming up in the show and
right now twitch is saying that they
think dead cells is gonna take that with
39% of the vote so we'll find out if
they're right when we come back
on the way a world premiere you won't
want to miss then ninja and Pepe the
king prawn resent the award for best
independent game and later we celebrate
the music of Red Dead Redemption - don't
stop streaming
is the Game Awards
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta step it out Terry Crews your
suit game needs to be tight look at me
man tighter
[Music]
they're really dressed to kill
[Music]
included day one with Xbox games has
joined today the ESO community has been
nothing but kind and supportive
everyone gets behind each other their
very touching to see it is great for us
not only for the game but for us as a
race so in the television series that
I'm currently working on the outpost I
play a night captain
and in Elder Scrolls online I play a
magic award
I'm woody go UFC middleweight champion
not by an imperial tank and elder
scrolls online ah I'm frisky Lee and I
play a Red Guard stamina Dragon Knight
and Elder Scrolls online even though my
brother has been far too busy to play
with me recently
[Music]
welcome back to the game Awards we have
so much work show coming for you lots
new games lots of awards and right now
I'd like to announce some of the other
Award winners across some other
categories the nominees for our Best
Debut indie game this is recognizing a
small studio making its first project
the nominees were donut county florence
moss the messenger
yoku silent express and the game award
goes to the messenger congratulations
also a Canadian studio there's something
going on here all right next up best
fighting game when those nominees this
year are BlazBlue Dragonball Fighters
Soul Calibur 6 Street Fighter 5 arcade
edition and the winner for best fighting
game Dragon Ball fighters a crowd
favorite the best family game the
nominees this year are Mario Tennis Aces
Nintendo labo overcooked 2 star length
battle for Atlas and Super Mario Party
and the game award goes to overcooked -
another genre category for best strategy
game those nominees the banner saga 3
battle tech frost punk into the breach
and they'll curia chronicles 4 and the
winner for best strategy game into the
breach congratulations subset games
alright well we've got a lot more show
ahead for you tonight and we've got the
big awards we've got best game Direction
game of the year and so much more but
right now it's time to look at another
game announcement world premiere
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
you've found me at last I suspect you
have questions
he's a mega popular streamer and he's a
mega popular steamer here are ninja and
from the Muppets today the king prawn
hey congratulations my friend on the big
win thank you thank you thank you let me
get a selfie come on see ya that's a
good shelf in my friend did you just say
shelf shelf e CC it's a crustacean thing
oh no no no that wasn't a good one we
didn't get a good one my eyes were
closed say manchego
manchego that's a good one that's a good
one oh I'm gonna get some big V bucks
for this okay that's a that's a fork
knife reference did you say fork knife
it's uh it's actually pronounced for
tonight no I don't feel so
oh no but believe me definitely III know
it's it's it's for tonight right guys
it's for tonight
yeah well I hate to disagree with
everyone's but you're wrong for tonight
makes no sense for tonight is only two
weeks and I know I've spent a lot more
time than two weeks playing this game
sangria
sangria all right yeah look we're
supposed to be presenting the award for
best independent game
give me can we do that please sure - do
what you gotta do I'm gonna take some
shellfish okay all right this award is
for the best game made outside of the
triple-a system there's a good one did
you say triple-a yeah it's amazing what
they do without batteries these days and
here are the nominees Oh nominees best
independent games
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
alright alright and the award goes to
ninja hold on my friend let's get one
more big shelfie with the big cloud in
the background okay everybody get crazy
scream shelfie shelfing that's a good
one okay my friend continue please
alright and now the best independent
game goes to how to do this alone Oh
hard the award goes to Celeste
[Applause]
tonight Celeste also wins the games for
impact award
[Applause]
oh man
this is ridiculous oh there's a few team
members who can be here tonight and I
know they're watching so Gabby and spen
and the power of guys we love you and we
wish you're here and we're nothing
without our support networks so thanks
to like our our partners and their
family and our friends who are amazing
and pretty sure my parents account my
parents account for like half of our
votes so hi mom and dad I love you so we
got like completely lost in the work and
making this game and we kind of forgot
that people would eventually play it so
the reception has just been like really
overwhelming and man my heart is beating
so fast I'm like at a loss for things to
say all year about the reception so
there is one thing I want to say though
if Celeste has helped you come to terms
with mental illness I just want to say
that you deserve credit for that that
change came from inside of you and
you're capable of a lot more thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we got much more show to come
we got a muppet on the show finally so
I'm very personally happy Pepe thank you
for joining us all right tonight you can
find special offers on all the nominated
games across Xbox Nintendo eShop steam
and PlayStation Store so make sure to
check out those offers tonight and over
the next few days of course we are
trending number one worldwide on Twitter
I want to thank everyone for talking
about the show you can see some of these
amazing tweets everyone's talking about
all things Game Awards right now very
exciting stuff all right
there's another game launching tonight
it's human heads new games survived by
it's launching right now on Steam you
can play now in early access and it's
published by the folks at Digital
Extremes developers of warframe here's a
first look at survival
[Music]
something dark has emerged from the
depths of the earth changing even the
cute and cuddly into the Damned and
deadly it is up to you to build your
arsenal
and set forth on an epic journey
[Music]
it is now up to you and probably many
more few descendants to set forth on an
epic journey to defeat this spreading
plague that sours our land
team up with friends and tackle menacing
for
or go it alone damn well you can try
it's totally up to you join a massive
online adventure to help rid the lands
of this mysterious and nearly
unstoppable force nearly unstoppable
there it is play for free and be among
the first to help build the heartlands
into something your ancestors would be
proud of
[Music]
survived by find it on Steam or the
access what's up everybody it's me
Melanie Mac here and on those days you
can catch me streaming some games but
today I wanted to hop in at the game
awards to talk about vaping and a simple
fact that if you vape you are four times
more likely to smoke cigarettes now
everybody knows that smoking cigarettes
is extremely bad for you but how they
being can lead to smoking cigarettes and
may not be as obvious the amount of
nicotine in just one Jihad is the same
as 20 cigarettes to learn more go to the
truth com2 join the cause to finish
smoking for good and enjoy the rest of
the game Ward's the stage and the lights
because they will already know when you
walk into a room you will see it in
their eyes here there whispers feel
their respect understand their fear your
friends will know and they will tell
their friend your mom will tell other
moms your little sister will know your
twin brothers will know so will their
twin friends even your dog will know
even me mix-a-lot
I don't know this game store over will
know and solo these guys and so will she
and the actual creator of magic will
also know because when you're the
world's number one magic player the
world will know
all right I'm here with Elaine Chase the
vice president of eSports for Magic the
Gathering
Elaine some fun cameos in that piece
what will the world know tell us so Jeff
I am so excited to be here tonight to
announce magic the gatherings new
eSports and competitive gaming program
in 2019 we have 10 million dollars in
prize money on the line across digital
and tabletop magic Wow all right that's
that's a lot of money a big big prize
out when is it going to start next year
it all kicks off in March at PAX East in
Boston where we're hosting a 1 million
dollar mythic Invitational on MTG Arena
that's a lot of money how do people get
on board if they want to jump in here oh
that's easy just download and start
playing
MTG arena I've got something special for
the audience tonight special things what
do you have for us if you use the code
game Awards you'll receive an eSports
starter kit with some awesome cards to
play awesome all right well Elaine thank
you so much it's great to have magic
part of the game Awards have a great
evening thank you we have a lot more
show to come up tonight a winner tonight
for a bunch of awards Red Dead
Redemption to created a new standard
among the beautiful landscapes and
meticulous detail to its world there is
also a brilliant score that transported
us straight to America in 1899 here
tonight as well surprise to perform a
medley of music from Red Dead Redemption
to are a pair of Grammy Award winners
Daniel Lanois
with his band and fellow Grammy Award
winning vocalist Rihanna and Ganon's
enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
your day is done
the tasks are you battled ha the wars
won you did your worst you tried your
best now it's time to rest now it's time
to rest
[Music]
see this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this feeling deep inside I don't down
that I'm homeward bound
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stern
[Music]
mr. Kashi
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. Grassi
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
Briana Daniel thank you that was
absolutely beautiful
and we want to thank the band for that
amazing performance it's always a thrill
for me to bring the music from games to
life on our stage and I think we did it
better than we've ever done it before so
thank you so much guys for doing that
right now let's take a trip back to
Hawkins Indiana to do this let's engage
you should go someone's here
[Music]
please welcome the creators of the
Netflix streaming phenomenon stranger
things
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys it is very cool to be
here we were what six years old when we
received this brand new system called
Nintendo for Christmas and we've been
gaming ever since we think this has been
a particularly incredible year for games
which is kind of unfortunate for Netflix
because playing your games has probably
delayed a release by at least what a
month at least for sure but I mean Red
Dead got a war ass robot I mean come on
it's incredible anyway we're glad we
could be here tonight to announce a new
stranger things video game from Netflix
and bonus xp it follows the events of
season three with a few surprises of its
own and you can play co-op on Xbox
switch and PC and we've also made a big
graphical leap this year we're up to 16
bits so watch out Rockstar alright let's
take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's the creative director at
NetherRealm Studios and the co-creator
of Mortal Kombat and injustice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you it's great to be back here at
the Game Awards it's my honor tonight to
present the award for best sports or
racing game let's check out the nominees
best sports racing game
[Applause]
[Music]
I knew with his drum attack you were
[ __ ] taco we got it I'm trying to fish
right before you dump that if you don't
get a bullet in your long-term 21
immortal we're never that lawyer to my
brother coming bird dog cuz I cheat and
I'm flash better and I love winning I'm
upset if this attack if you have a
charter
[Music]
get you out the ground just a nukkie to
the flow here let's go blow for blow
yeah let's go toe-to-toe when it's time
to batter down never ever show when it's
time to batter I'm the first one in the
door and it though
here we go
[Music]
sorry actually sorry about that I think
they played the wrong video actually
here are the real nominees for best
sports or racing game best sports racing
games
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the game award goes to Forza horizon
floor
[Music]
[Music]
Wow Edie Boone give it up for ad what a
bit what revision are in legend so there
has been so many people working on the
force of franchise it's a huge honor to
accept this on their behalf for surprise
and for is now our best-selling horizon
game millions of people have played it
both by buying the game and playing it
in game paths and it's just been an
incredible honor to watch the team is
working really hard as you saw we have a
whole new update with fortune Island
coming on December 13th and we're just
getting started so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to tell you about a boy ooh is it
me please save your questions to the end
rasputin okay he was uniquely talented
Acrobat but also a gifted psychic don't
forget my canoeing passion it was a big
pain in the neck
but somebody messed up and let him into
the sack Oh nuts
that was youth agent role this 10 year
old circus runaway was somehow allowed
to join an international group of
psychic super spies and now he's headed
to our main headquarters right into the
mother lode man you guys really like
puns but he better wise up this is no
summer camp
the mother lobe has its own way of doing
things its own way of protecting itself
from outsiders its fair share of
dangerous hidden secrets if they ever
got out things would never be the same
again for the SACU nuts we're friends
family for you
listen Rasputin their thoughts that
should never be opened not all mines are
safe to read some blades are better off
then open don't worry I won't do
anything crazy
and whatever you do just leave me out of
it who is that honey Peppa boar bacon
[Music]
[Music]
Psychonauts to first announce here a
couple years ago tim schafer thinking
are you great too we'll see you next
year I hope I'm now joined by Phil
Spencer the head of Xbox we saw you at
the the top of the show with your new
buddies Reggie and your longtime buddies
Reggie in filler
yeah I know really Jon you deserve
credit for putting that moment together
with Reggie Sean and I you push to make
that happen I think it's great to show
the industry coming together and Jeff
did that so you gots on that Thank You
Phil I appreciate you being a part of it
I think it's so important to have all
this year we just love games as you said
and we're here to celebrate so it's
let's talk about Xbox though it's been a
big year for Xbox just had EXO 18 in
Mexico City house 18 been going for you
guys yeah I waited pretty good here what
you do better we had a pretty good year
added some Studios ship some good games
see if thieves ship state of decay forts
arise it was great to see ports horizon
for when an award ship the adaptive
controller this last year something I'm
very proud of ya know it's been a good
year and news coming about Xbox we saw
the guy supposed to be a wild card up
here atlas coming next year to game
preview right yeah I mean we have a long
relationship with Studio wild card they
were one of our earlier game preview
team's game crew he really helps
developers always trying to build
programs to help developers are Aidid
Xbox program game paths I mean all these
things just to help developers reach as
many gamers as possible well speaking of
game pass let's talk about that what can
you tell us about game paths seems like
everything's coming to game past now
right yeah we had mutant year zero
people playing that game this week
launch launched in a game paths we have
ashen launching right now into game pads
which is incredible
yeah people are gonna go play that next
next week kingdoms two crowns next week
all of those in-game paths all part of
winter of arcade we mentioned bring in
winter of arcade back it's great to have
all those games coming and launching
both for sale and any game past get as
many players as we can I love you guys
exploring the smaller it is same thing
with me here at the awards want the big
games in the small games and that's what
makes this industry so edsells up such a
good game I know those guys where their
award 2019 obviously lots of big stuff
coming from you guys
what can you tell us about 2019 yeah we
got crackdown 3 we're gonna be launching
that we've got gears 5 which would just
be incredible one of my favorite
franchises have come out this generation
for us Ori seeing the next Ori come out
you know it's gonna be back here at e3
it's will be incredible right here in
this theater I mean it's gonna be 20
night this year was it was an awesome
year for gamers and I look at next year
and I think it's just lined up to be yet
another better year all right and also
we should talk about Devil May Cry we
saw the performance of Devil Trigger you
announced that here in this theater at
e3 right did I mean the support we've
had captains awesome and just seeing the
game and people don't know Devil May Cry
to be launching their beta tomorrow on
Xbox so people can go out and play demo
if Demirel we cry on xbox tomorrow so
people can go give that a try and just
see that crazy engine with that game
it's gonna be great all right and that's
coming first Xbox write the demo first
on xbox that's alright we'll check it
out Devil May Cry 5 Phil great to have
you here at the Game Awards we hope to
have you here every year along with
everyone in the industry and right now
let's take a look at some brand-new
stuff from Devil May Cry
[Applause]
I will show you
you're worse
[Music]
what evil lurks I must destroy
all right time to kick some ass
why don't you tell me everything about
this job a powerful demon is about to
resurrect and we need your help Dante
[Music]
games play best on Xbox one
[Music]
you know being in a refugee camp is not
easy you know what is neck what world
are you going to leave tomorrow are
you're not going to leave tomorrow one
day I asked my mom to buy from your
computer she said that money for almost
three years it was like that woman that
just done everything like everything is
possible for me seventy-three percent of
the population in South Sudan is under
the age of 30 they are born in world
they were raised up in war so their
mindset and attitude is all about war I
decided to teach myself programming so
that I can make game for peace I made a
game called Salam Salam is an Arabic
word and mean peace so what did you as a
player you have to stop the bomb from
destroying the communities and you know
people start playing the game in the
refugee camp and bringing the people
together and I have the passion and the
capability to change the wall and make a
difference coming up world will change
in fortnight
and represent the award for best game
direction and later directing two of the
Russo brothers assemble on stage and
more music from the Game Awards
orchestra the Game Awards we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the beginning there was nothing and
then there was blight
[Music]
she's the composer of select and a
member of the Game Awards Orchestra
tonight please welcome letter rays
[Applause]
as demonstrated tonight games require
hundreds of elements from music and art
to acting writing programming and design
great direction is evident when the work
of hundreds somehow combines into a
unified creative vision here are the
nominees for best game Direction best
game direction
[Music]
I didn't choose to be
[Music]
the road ahead is long and unforgiving
place will play
look next time leave the fighting to the
pros
we don't want to kill any of you
but we will
and the game award goes to God award
tonight
God of War also be
an adventure game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow all right
I'm not gonna cry tonight all right
um first I want to sing Soni for the
support and faith you foolishly placed
in me and our great team over at Santa
Monica to my amazing wife and my son
helo my inspirations throughout all of
this to the unbelievable team that I
have been blessed with at Santa Monica
every human being who put so much of
themselves please wrap it up into this
game I am forever thankful for all of
you and all the work for the casts that
we were blessed with you guys are
amazing you brought it every single day
and elevated the work that we wrote on
the page beyond what we could have ever
imagined it so thank you to David Jaffe
who created all this I wouldn't even be
here if he hadn't done that 2018 has
been an absolutely bananas year for
games we are all lucky that every
creator out there every creator in this
audience every creator out there in the
world is absolutely crushing it
motivating me and everybody else to work
even harder but it wouldn't even be
worth it or even we wouldn't be driven
without all the fans out there without
all the people who love games all games
all throughout the industry we have an
amazing community and there's so much
more that unites us than divides us so
thank you everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fortnight season seven launched this
morning he's had a busy day but here he
has on the game Ward stage yet again
Donald mustard Donald welcome to the
show and congratulations on such an
insane year oh thank you it's been a
insane and crazy year and we're just
humbled and grateful for all the players
everywhere for playing for tonight and
for helping us build the game with them
well you guys I know it's it's an
ongoing game as you guys are our nominee
tonight so season seven started this
morning what can you tell us about
season seven so season seven as you just
saw in the trailer a big mysterious
iceberg has crashed with the island and
it's brought with it airplanes and zip
lines and a whole bunch of other
surprises that players will be
uncovering in the weeks to come
and you also announced the creative mode
right yes fortnight creative is
launching on December 13th so next week
for net creative is a mode a brand new
mode where everyone will be given their
own private island where you can design
your own games and build whatever you
want with your friends now this is a
this is a real labor of love for us we
are all passionate game designers and we
think everyone is a game designer and
our goal is to let you build your own
Fortnight Wow now it's it's rough this
is early that's early early early access
is actually available right now so if
you want to get into it right the second
go pick up a battle pass and you can
join in right now in this early access
week okay I hear there's there's maybe
something a little more there is so just
in the few hours that it's been out I've
seen just already millions of people
building crazy crazy stuff and we
suspected that might happen yes and the
map is kind of crowded and on the island
and we figured we needed to clear out a
little space to make room for some stuff
so let's head over to the game now see
what's happened in the fortnight world
it's ray
[Music]
now that literally just happened in the
game right Donald
so what you just saw is the emergence of
the block so the block is a a new space
where we will be featuring the best and
the coolest content created by you and
we will be bringing it into the battle
royale map right on the island and
replace it there for everyone to see
okay how you gonna pick we're gonna all
pick it together okay and so there's
gonna be new stuff coming there all the
time and we think this is gonna be an
incredible way for us to all continue to
build this game together all right so
the block if I if I let afford that
right now I'd see the block yeah the
risky risky reels is gone goodbye risky
rails lock is there but you know don't I
I'm a big movie fan okay we'll find a
way to get movies back in that well
we'll work on it all right well the
block I creative bode Donald thanks so
much for stopping by the game Awards we
can't wait to see where you take for
tonight in the future all right so we've
got much more Game Awards ahead right
now we've got a brand new look at rage
to check out this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our latest pass ticket Tevye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
up next the Russo brothers precise best
ongoing game and then the game Awards
Orchestra celebrates the nominees for
game of the year who will win will it be
Red Dead Redemption to God of War or
will another game take home the crown
it's all coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
critics agree that final fantasy xiv
online rises above expectations
a world that grows beyond imagination
with inspiring lands to see
as well as some familiar roads to
revisit
[Applause]
final fantasy xiv online continues to
astound players worldwide
begin your adventure live your story
fight your way
final fantasy xiv online plate for free
now
[Applause]
Super Smash Brothers ultimate coming
soon very very soon
the optelec showdown is about to begin
and the winner is everyone
[Music]
[Music]
stay alive and be the one abdi mobile
play three now in pub G mobile there can
only be one winner that's kind of hard
when you're facing over a million people
every day if you think you have what it
takes download the game right now it's
free the only thing you have to lose is
bragging rights
[Music]
of the mobile play three now please
welcome the directing duo behind
Avengers infinity war Joe and Anthony
Russo
[Applause]
[Music]
hello my brother and I are thrilled to
be here tonight to hand out the award
for the best ongoing game this award is
for those games that continue to get
better and better after their initial
release with new adventures and
experiences for their fans originally
there were 10 nominees in this category
but then they asked us to present the
award and now there are only five sorry
best ongoing game
[Music]
[Music]
and the game award goes to fortnight
[Applause]
fortnight also wins for best multiplayer
game
[Applause]
the Russo brothers like we we love you
so much all of us right thank you so
much for everything you guys have done
for us I represent just the tiniest
portion of a team that just works so
hard every day to make the game that is
for tonight there is just so many people
pouring their souls their talent their
time into trying every day to bring all
the people playing that game joy and
delight that's it that's all that's our
mission is how can we just bring joy and
delight to people and and we're so
grateful we're so grateful for all the
people who have come on this journey
with us who've played for at night who
continue to play it every day and and
with us help make the game better this
is a been an extremely humbling year for
us at epic as we have really learned and
tried to just do something that felt
wonderful to us and we're just so glad
that there's so many of you that that
agree with us and that are playing the
game with us so I imagine that almost
everyone here a reason why you are in
the game industry or why you make games
or love games is because it feels like a
new medium and it really is games aren't
that old and I think that's what's so
exciting for me every day is that
feeling that there's something over the
horizon right and it feels like we're
there again that we're on the cusp as an
industry of new amazing experiences and
I'm just so grateful for all of you
we're all kind of one big team all of us
in this industry really pushing this
medium
and I'm so grateful for it thank you
guys so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there are still lots of amazing moments
coming up in the show we've got more
performances and of course the game of
the Year announcement uh-oh whoa what's
going on okay
this is Joker I've infiltrated the
theater wait seriously
he went alone to the game Awards but
it's so far away why is he there there's
only one thing that phantom thieves of
hearts specialize in they have to steal
a treasure have you already sent a
calling card we're not the ones sending
a card this time in fact we've been
invited invited to steal the greatest
treasure of all
[Music]
we'll be going up against the best of
the best can't wait to see our fearless
leaders show his stuff
persona
I am thou thou art I show the strength
of thy will and rage against all
challengers
[Music]
Oh Reggie Reggie wretch
we meet again quite the surprise so all
right so Super Smash Brothers coming out
tonight but it looks like I know a great
choice of shirt here Reggie the Internet
is going crazy the announcement of Joker
persona 5 coming to Smash Brothers
everyone's in this game everyone's in
this game right so we've said that Super
Smash Brothers ultimate it is the
biggest crossover in video game history
dare I say the biggest crossover in
entertainment so brothers might have
some and and so and so yes you know the
the the games about to launch were super
excited were super excited to give the
fans the opportunity to summon or
persona into the game amazing alright so
you said challenger pack one so these
are the the DLC fighters that will come
out correct yeah and so this gives you a
flavor of how we're approaching the DLC
so the DLC there's going to be five
characters each character will come with
a stage it'll come with a collection of
music these are going to be characters
that are new to the series just like
Joker from persona 5 characters that you
would not anticipate to be in Super
Smash Brothers ultimate we're super
excited about this the fans can go and
they could get their fighters pass to
get all of the five fighters that will
be coming to the series we're
tremendously excited well I would think
you'd be even more excited because
tonight
smash is about to launch right smash is
about to launch and
you know you needed to have a really
good show for me to be here versus
you've been through your presentation
sure everything's going great for the
launch so yeah we're super excited
smash is just minutes away yes and it's
gonna be fantastic
all right well Reggie you've been here
every year first for the game where it's
really appreciated and before we go
maybe we should head to the stage for
the Game Awards Orchestra a little
something for Super Smash Brothers
Reggie great to see you enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one more big score we got enough money
to leave what do you think
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah nothing means more to me than this
game I would kill for doubt happily dive
I wish things were difficult what it
wanted us to change trust me Martha just
one is a god damn straight
I don't want to kill all these food
touch just you
what about loyalty what matter you do is
your goddamned home
ladies us for him
Red Dead Redemption - oh now rated M for
Mature
[Applause]
we wanted to start with this game
building a sound identity along with
lares sort of evolved personality so we
kind of started from scratch for this
one and really thought about what is
Lara's mindset and how we can bring that
forward with the sound
when I heard the first time the jungle
in dolby atmos i was that's that's
incredible we're all conditioned to look
at it at a 2d image and trick ourselves
to believe that it's it's more than a 2d
image but a lot of times you think it
goes this way but what at Mawson this
huge soundscape it makes it feel like
the coverage in a sound blanket and it's
magical when we build a world you don't
just build a story you're building a
world and that's what the Dolby Atmos
really drinks to the media where you're
feeling that you are this character
that's you all are
[Music]
all right it's finally that time here to
present our final award as a member of
the team that won game of the year in
2016 and won again last year for best
ongoing game from overwatch here's the
vice president of Blizzard Entertainment
Jeff
Kaplan
[Applause]
[Music]
two years ago we were honored to be up
here to accept the game of the year for
overwatch it was so awesome and it meant
so much to our team it's so special
right now to be able to share that with
another studio here to celebrate all of
the nominees for a game of the year the
Game Awards Orchestra
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Lottie Dottie who gets the Gotti here it
goes all right and the game award for
game of the year goes to God of War
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
who
Wow so unexpected thank you everybody
a great night for all of us thank you
and thanks so much the team back in
Santa Monica is just an amazing amazing
group of talent that really pulled
together to realize this beautiful
vision that pori Cory brought to the
franchise reboot for God of War I'm so
thankful that Cory returned back to the
studio and joined our family once again
and you are an amazing visionary love
your partnership you me Aang it's really
hard to see the behind the scenes work
that goes into producing a game like God
of War and the triumphs that it is
without Yumi's steadfast ability to
thread that very tricky production
needle and the balance with Cory's and
the team's creative vision we would not
be where we are on this stage today so
thank you to you me and the entire
production team
and you guys the fans around the world
together we all dream big dreams and
that's an amazing feeling every day when
we walked into the studio to create
something like God of War I want to
thank my children for being the very
best and all of the families throughout
the God of War team who rode this wave
with us thank you so much for the
support that we were given over the
course of many many months many hours
many years
and lastly Scott rode a tremendous
support to the Santa Monica studio
Shuhei Yoshida and Shawn Layden really
stood behind us for a studio reboot and
re-envisioning of this franchise which
takes a lot of guts at that level and
the entire PlayStation family who stood
behind us as in that partnership over
many years to really realize what this
franchise was capable of thank you
everyone
Cory I'll be quick because they're
flashing the please wrap it up but I
just want to say every single game that
was nominated up here is an absolute
frickin masterpiece please give it up
for all of them and again please give it
up for every creator and that is
creators of games creators of movies
creators of comic books creators of
every single thing that enriches our
lives that makes us believe that magic
is real all right I love yo
[Applause]
congratulations to God work team for
winning game of the year let's check the
twitch leaderboard and see who was the
most successful predicting all the
winners tonight amazing well it's been a
great year for games as everyone has
said thank you so much for watching the
Game Awards we'll see you next year for
the game awards 2019 good night I really
appreciate it thank you everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you